kyle what's up i struggle with like
stress or anxiety or whatever you want
to call it really bad
um i get stressed about everything some
large so i'm not
like i mean i think it comes a lot from
like always going top speed and having
so much to do
and working in a high stress high octane
job
i get stress about like getting out the
door on time in the morning when i'm
waking up early enough i get stressed
that the work i do
is not good enough even though i know it
is i get stressed about bad drivers and
just everyday things like that and then
i get tense and angry and my blood
pressure gets high
yeah and my girlfriend who works in the
medical field
is recommending that i look into an ss
into getting prescribed onto it like an
ssri
and she struggled with a lot of these
same kinds of things and her doctor
recommended it and it's worked great for
her
and i'm just kind of unsure about it and
looking for advice because i know you
say a lot of times like you know
all this stuff is just alarm systems and
i don't know if it's good to mask it or
if
it's or whatever so well man i
appreciate your vulnerability here
um somebody who struggles with control
it's hard for them to be vulnerable so
i appreciate you reaching out man um i i
can
hear in your voice this is not an easy
call to make how long have you
been working to control everything in
your world
my guess is since you were little yeah
my whole life
i mean i think i get a lot from my dad
it's just like okay
i've always kind of been like the guy
who takes leadership in most roles and i
feel like i am a good leader but then
it's when i put in roles of
non-leadership i i struggle because
you want to take it and own it right
right what
is if you were to um evaluate you on
your leadership performance what is
something
negative that somebody who worked for
you would say about you
um probably that i'm not always the best
at like implementing other people's
ideas and stuff like i definitely like
to take
and listen to other people's ideas and
implement like pieces and parts of it
but
ultimately probably just try to keep it
as my plan still
okay but with maybe some of their ideas
okay
so this this
stress this frustration that you feel um
it's a ultimately at the end of the day
and i take a lot of flack for this but
um kyle i'm you i've been you most of my
life
and to feel this way is a choice
and i hate to say it that way because
i'm this is the pot talking to the
kettle here
until i spent some hard hard time
putting space in my day realizing that
the best roi of my time was actually
going to sleep
the best roi of my time was sitting with
other human beings and listening to them
that my value was not about what advice
i could give and what
thing i could muscle through and clinch
and flex and pump through
and it took years brother for me to get
that message through my thick head and
i'm still wrestling with it
but what you find man is your heart rate
goes way down
you're way more patient on the road you
drive the speed limit sometimes even
which sounds crazy
right i actually find that's a pretty
calming thing to do sometimes
it is right and like in the slow lane
yeah and listen you feel like you're
doing earth a service by following the
law
right can you imagine like
50 years ago the idea of going 70 was
like a rocket ship and now that's what
you're doing to calm so
that's a temporary a temporary move
right
my guess one thing this also like leads
into is like i've been
thinking about making a job change
because my current job is like
6am to 8pm it's 100 travel all the time
and i never get to have a community and
so i'm looking at making a switch to a
job that's
settled somewhere with my girlfriend
that i don't have to travel all the time
and it's
calmer hours more normal hours and they
like really work
focus on work-life balance where my
current one doesn't and hey kyle listen
i mean
i absolutely 1000 support that but
here's the one catch to it
whatever new job you get you're going to
go with you
no matter what job you get what salary
you get
somebody calls you out of the blue and
says hey i want you to mow my neighbor's
yard
i'm going to give you 250 000 a year and
you'd be like
really what else that's it kyle's going
to go with you
and you are going to turn whatever new
job you get into
into a third rail electrified fence for
you and everybody around you because
that's that's the energy level you
operate at because in your soul
you believe your value is based on how
fast and long and hard you can go
and somewhere somebody whether it was
your old man or your mom or your friends
or a combination of whatever ecosystem
you grew up in
told you that rest is for lazy losers
and income income performance
go that's how we're gonna that's what a
man does right that's how you get it
that's how you do it go go go
and you're right you're gonna make a lot
of money you can be on the road and you
can crush it and kill it and devour it
and then
last i looked men lead planet earth
in money and wealth and accumulation and
men lead earth
and cancer stroke heart attacks
and on and on and on right
right we are proving and achieving
ourselves to death
and so my question for you is
where did you hear for the first time
that your value is in what you did
and how fast and how far you went
man i don't know it's just is that
lifelong thing of
is it ringing true you know yeah so
listen to me kyle
how old are you 27
just recently 27. so here's my guess
by 35 you'll have some sort of weird
physical thing if you don't already
it'll be a really weird thing in your
neck your knees are going to hurt
something's going to be
physical on you are you already there do
you have a thing
yeah i've gained a lot of weight because
of stress and work and stuff like that
and now
everything hurts okay
and so your body's hollering at you
we're not okay
right right
and here's the deal that girlfriend
loves you or she wouldn't be trying to
come up with solutions she would have
just bailed on you it's pretty cool that
you have her in your life
here's what an ssri will do here's what
it did for me
it will slow the alarms down so that you
can actually do the work
you can actually sit down and meet with
people you can go talk to a counselor
you can
if you don't want to go sit in the
presence of somebody which i recommend
you can
i've got a partnership with betterhelp
right you can get online and get a
therapist that way
but it will help you slow down and do
that work
it is not a solution long term and most
people
take it and then they it allows them to
ex
stay at or accelerate their current pace
how much weight have you gained in the
last few years
like 130 pounds yeah
what's the end road for you
what do you mean you're 27 what's uh 45
year old kyle looking like
not physically but pay me a picture more
than anything i want to be
i want to be like a good dad and husband
more than any like career aspirations
but like it's hard for me to pull myself
away from it
how come i don't know it's
the you know tell me if you're not
moving you're dead
kind of saying yeah if you're not if
you're not moving you're dying
right yeah so i want to tell you this
like if you waste an hour and a day or
something like that you should have been
doing something else
there you go there you go
and so you're listen man you've been
redlining that machine
for 20 years now
and i'm telling you i work really hard i
work real hard
and i was up at five this morning
exercise like i'm all about work hard
okay and i won't go to bed until late
tonight and i'm working on a book at the
hou like
i'm all about working hard but i also
canceled an event
at somebody's house tonight so i could
go sit at a baseball game
and so i could go have dinner with my
family and i'm not saying i'm great dude
i'm still figuring this out myself
but i had to build in time today with be
with people and i've got a phone call
after this show's over
right you got to build it in it's got to
be part of your life and it starts with
you valuing kyle and right now you don't
you're running brother you're running
you're running you're running
and here's what i want to tell you
you're worth a good night's sleep
you're worth an exercise routine you're
worth eating well you're worth that girl
walking in and hugging you so tight you
can't breathe
and i want that for you kyle so bad way
more than i want some
you to get another sale or another
whatever it is you do
okay okay so yeah if if
going to see a psychiatrist is gonna
help but i don't want you to put a pill
in your mouth until you work with that
psychiatrist to get a plan
for how long you're gonna do this and
it's gonna have to come with a lot of
behavioral modifications
choosing to change the way you live
okay okay there's something there's
something
you're not gonna do it though huh i want
to
okay so why aren't you going to choose
it i can hear it and you're going to be
like all right bro cool
and you're going to hang up and you're
going to be like that sucked and you're
going to have like two beers tonight and
then tomorrow you'll be back at it
no i mean like i definitely want to do
this i just don't know where to start i
guess but i mean
looking for a psychiatrist will be the
first part all right here's what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna send you a copy
of my redefining anxiety book i'm gonna
send to you for free okay stay on the
line and kelly's gonna mail it to you
okay okay and um
i want you to commit to me today before
you go see a psychiatrist i want you to
go see a counselor
okay actually you know what if you've
gained 130 pounds in last year too don't
you go see a medical doctor
okay you got a lot going on and i want
you to sit down and tell somebody
um not your physical symptoms i want you
to tell them i'm not okay
i'm tired of running and running and
running and running
and i want to make some lifestyle
changes and
if the doctor says well we can just give
you a pill for that i want you to go say
well no thank you and go see another
doctor
okay okay i want you to find someone who
will listen to you and we'll talk with
you
and we'll say hey we're going to give
you some medication if we need to but
we're also going to connect you with
a counselor and we're going to get you
on a plan because this is a
this is a a absolutely solvable
challenge
and you're up for it if you put this
much energy
in the energy you put into staying alive
and making that next sale
into being well and whole dude you're
gonna be the greatest dad ever
you're gonna be the most extraordinary
husband of all time
and then you know what your business
wins will come comically easy to you
because doing it from a platform of
sleep and wholeness and wellness in
relationship dude
okay and what i'll tell you is when i
was your age i got called in
um maybe i was a little bit old uh maybe
34 35
i had a buddy who was a college
president and i i wanted a job
and he called me and said i can't hire
you because you're electric
you're a tuning fork in every room you
walk into you're just
his exact words where you're too
volatile does that sound familiar to you
yeah that's actually been written on one
of my uh reports once
now fast forward a few years i'm the
calmest guy
of my friends know okay so i want to
stand out there and say
it's hard work but you're going to get
there but it all starts with you being
able to look in the mirror and say i'm
worth getting well
and i'm telling you guys as a guy who's
never met you you are one thousand
percent
okay well no still like hearing you on
the radio
now like knowing if you were like this
it would i mean that's definitely a plan
that i want to follow and do
that's awesome brother that's awesome
awesome awesome
it starts with you look in the mirror
look at that girlfriend of yours tonight
tomorrow
i want you to look her in the eye and
say i'm ready to make some life changes
and i'm so grateful that you've stuck
with me and i've been hard to be with
for the last few years
today things are going to be different
starting today
we're going to go for a walk after
dinner tonight
and then in the morning i'm not going to
do some crazy workout plan but in the
morning i'm going to get up and i'm
going to write five things i'm grateful
for then i'm gonna go for a walk
and then i'm gonna make an appointment
with a doctor a local doctor she works
in the field so she can hook you up with
somebody good
and you're gonna start a journey of
taking a left turn in your life man
and i can't wait i want you to call me
every step of the way
every time you're down 25 or 50 pounds i
want you to call me
every time somebody cuts you off and you
bow your head and you say a quick prayer
form and say i hope they're getting to
the hospital soon
instead of swearing god cut me off
i'm gonna get a bigger truck so instead
of just going man hope they're doing
okay
i want you to call me every step of the
way as you turn this thing around
get people to walk with you so grateful
for the call brother kyle
thank you so so so much